[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana a un
programa de radio francia internacional
ley de france 24 esta semana ponemos el
foco en aquellas revueltas que
sacudieron al mundo árabe en 2011 las
llamadas primaveras árabes una década
después analizamos las que tuvieron
algún fruto las que fracasaron o las que
acabaron en conflictos aún no resueltos
me acompañan para analizarlo en este
estudio tres invitados que conocen muy
bien el mundo árabe
logan perpignan iván periodista
independiente bienvenido hola buenas
charla guerra periodista de origen 21
bienvenida a la y kris de non periodista
en orient 21 nuevo vídeo periodista que
estuvo en 2011 en egipto en libia y
luego en siria y en bahrein no he venido
crisis versos
diez años después la primavera de las
primaveras árabes hoy en en primera
plana
[Música]
hace 10 años el movimiento de protestas
de la primavera árabe tomó por asalto
oriente medio y el norte de áfrica
desencadenando en parte en parte
desencadenado por la muerte ocurrida en
enero de 2011 de mohamed buazizi un
vendedor ambulante tunecino que se
prendió fuego para desafiar el orden
establecido lo cual avivó la llama del
fervor revolucionario en toda la región
sin embargo aunque los primeros días de
la primavera árabe estuvieron definidos
por esperanza por emoción y por
indignación en muchos países donde se
realizaron manifestaciones masivas
también se produjo brutales represiones
afluencia de intereses y combatientes
extranjeros y el surgimiento de guerras
civiles lo que enturbió el legado de la
revuelta panárabe a favor de la
democracia vamos a repasar algunas
portadas que nos deja la prensa en esta
efeméride el diario libération la
esperanza confiscada diez años después
de las primaveras árabes lakua egipto
diez años después la protesta con perfil
bajo dice el rotativo que a pesar de la
férrea represión del régimen actual
la posición sigue organizándose en redes
sociales estas revueltas también han
inspirado icónicas portadas
como esta que vende la revista 'time' el
mundo después de kaddafi simbolizando un
desierto sobre el rostro semi decapitado
del dictador de libia buenos diez años
después no podemos hacer un único
balance sino quizá varios balances según
estemos hablando de un país o de otro
pero de modo general que cambio logan en
aquel 2011 para siempre que que cambio
subrayaría en el mundo árabe cambió todo
y bueno desde 2011 muchas cosas
cambiaron también es muy difícil ahora
mismo de medir el éxito o el fracaso de
este experimento fue una reconstrucción
de sistemas políticos de paisajes más
mediáticos económicos culturales y
sociales y jesse años de diez años no
son suficientes para decir si es un
éxito o un fracaso pero si nos acercamos
un poco de estos países ahora se se
dibujan tres escenarios diferentes el
primero los países el país que conoció
una transición democrática que es túnez
y otro la vuelta al statu quo que es
egipto
y los países que están dentro de una de
una guerra infinita sería libia y yemen
estará en legados
es verdad que en aquellos momentos hubo
mucha esperanza hubo ilusión
no sé si ahora con la vista atrás desde
la atalaya del tiempo diez años después
y viendo todo lo que ha pasado en esta
década tanto caos tanta conflicto no sé
si legado con el que enfrentamos este
efeméride es más desolador de si
recordamos aquella esperanza de entonces
o no hay algunos puntos si depende de
los países como lo ha dicho el ojo pero
también yo creo que el principal punto o
la principal cosa que ha cambiado es la
posibilidad de saber que el cambio es
posible es a 10 a 10 años las
poblaciones o los pueblos en túnez en
egipto en libia etcétera no sabían qué
los regímenes de ben alí podrían caer y
eso sabemos que eso es posible hoy
entonces aunque la reflexión pueda ser
muy fuerte es muy dura pero la esperanza
se mantiene eso lo creo que eso es un
punto muy importante también hay cambios
reales hay si ponemos el ejemplo de
túnez hay un cambio de estructural del
sistema político elecciones democracia
hay una verdadera libertad de expresión
si es verdadero que aún hay problemas
socioeconómicos pero son problemas de
antes que ya teníamos problemas sociales
económicos es eso lo que durante la
dictadura de ben alí
no se podía saberlo porque no había
presa libre y no había libertad de
expresión pero esa es una bien
es la herencia de esos problemas durante
la dictadura y también hay otros
problemas que son internacionales como
por ejemplo el problema de la seguridad
y del terrorismo y por eso no son el
mundo árabe no es una excepción crisis
como visión general que cambio desde
aquel 2011 era un año inolvidable como
cuando veo las imágenes me fue algo
nostálgico porque había largas porciones
de la población no solamente en el mundo
árabe en el mundo del medio oriente que
querían democratizar el sistema político
corrompido corrupto ni esclerotizado
eran sistemas políticos bloqueados desde
la periodo post colonial pero totalmente
bloqueados en un sistema autoritario
aquí no no no había progre progreso y la
gente se hicieron ellos mismos
revolucionarios aunque no hay realmente
una revolución exitosa después pero un
sistema totalmente esclavizado
ha sido versionado por la movilización
popular quien ha realizado vamos a
buscar puntos en común porque si el
punto de origen fue túnez y si
pudiésemos observar algunos hilos
conductores en todas estas
movilizaciones aunque por supuesto los
países son distintos hablaremos sobre
todo en sociedades muy jóvenes y con muy
poco futuro como punto de origen para
todas estas movilizaciones logan claro
como se de egipto tiene ahorrarse
millones de habitantes y 60% de la
población tiene menos de 30 años en
estas condiciones y con los problemas
estructurales de estos países es
totalmente lógico que un día o el otro
la sociedad se levanta y que y que
extenda a acabar con estos regímenes que
esta gente quiere un futuro como es como
la mayoría de los países del mundo pero
en el mundo árabe es un poco más
complicado porque están a veces
aplastados entre poderes militares y
también entre partidos islamistas así
que puede ser más complicado para ellos
túnez fue la excepción un poco en cuanto
a cambios democráticos que sí se han
producido durante esta década recordemos
la constitución de 2014 pero parece que
los cambios democráticos no se han visto
plasmados en un futuro mejor para la
población seguimos seguimos viendo
desesperanza seguimos viendo gente que
sale a las calles desde tiempo hay una
no se ha trasladado esa respuesta
democrática para cambios sociales o
económicos más profundos sí bueno hay
varios problemas para lo que lo que dijo
lo ha propuesto de esas sociedades
jóvenes etcétera hay un problema común
también es que son sociedades con
problemas socioeconómicos porque
olvidamos que esas revoluciones son
revoluciones que sucedieron por causa de
problemas socioeconómicos desempleo
de pobreza marginación etc
entonces los problemas principales no
fueron para los primeros las primeras
personas personas que que se levantaron
en 2011 no fueran la democracia o las
elecciones libres era si me una un mejor
o una mejor vida un mejor futuro un
futuro si un futuro mejor y entonces
bien
muchísima injusto injusticia social y
bueno para túnez en ejemplo de todo así
podría ser mejor pero
hay algunos problemas de
de organización y por eso también creo
que el mundo árabe no es una excepción
es como en todo el mundo no hay una
verdadera organización con los partidos
políticos etcétera no es una estructura
política y entonces había sido después
de la revolución un poco difícil para
haber una vida política con partidos
fuertes con una para haber leyes fuertes
y para encontrar la contrarrevolución y
desarrollar con las semanas
socioeconómicas etcétera
luego vamos a hablar de las
contrarrevoluciones vamos saltando de
país en país aunque entendemos que las
realidades son muy distintas pero para
poder explicar un poco ese digamos los
grupos que explicaban al principio
egipto es un caso paradigmático de la
posición de occidente frente a la
primavera árabe como si se nos indica sé
que por ejemplo axis y viene a ser un
mal menor
al menos fiable para los intereses
occidentales cómo valoráis esta década
de relaciones con egipto en el qué
al principio occidente se vio muy bien
en el caso de egipto la posición de
accidente respecto a estos movimientos
no crisis ha sido una contrarrevolución
a la pero popular han sostenido por allá
por el fuego una con reducción golpe de
estado popular decimos de decir sí por
el fracaso del amor si por diferentes
razones pero hay una cosa que quería
decir es que un elemento central en el
levantamiento popular era que era masiva
no armado no por todos para desarrollar
nada y la ocupación permanente de los
lugares simbólicos como la plaza tahrir
y la plaza de la perla en bahrain y está
la cuestión de la ocupación permanente
es muy peligroso por los sistémicos en
ese tiempo político porque es como un
laboratorio de una nueva sociedad es un
laboratorio donde los diferentes grupos
se encuentran sedes de discutan y
planifican la próxima de la próxima
etapa para ir ir ir adelante este es
algo nuevo
como método de un levantamiento popular
que no hemos conocido antes hay una
buena cosa que quiero añadir hay
diferentes niveles de análisis francia y
europa pues mantenía con sus reacciones
con él sí sí porque en nombre de la
lucha contra el dicho islamismo radical
y contra el terrorismo y por los lazos
comerciales los eeuu un poco diferente
es más en el nombre del conflicto
israelo palestino israelí palestino y
porque los estados siempre vieron a
egipto como un polo de estabilidad desde
el final de los años 70 así que era esta
cosa más importante que todo en eso no
cambia que me vaivén y macrón en la
actualidad vayan a dejar de apoyar por
ejemplo a justice y por esta misma razón
no
para añadir también por egipto
hablando de contar de evolución y de las
relaciones con el occidente el problema
me parece el problema que es se mira
siempre al mundo árabe a través del
prisma un prisma muy dicotómico de la
seguridad o la estabilidad y la
desorganización y entonces él
el peligro terrorista etcétera y
desgraciadamente eso
sucedió a eso el apoyo a regímenes que
el régimen de si se hoy en en egipto es
mucho más peor que el régimen de mumar
es una dictadura militar
terrible es horrible el nombre de los
oponentes de militantes de derechos
humanos en el cartel en egipto es una
situación terrible y entonces si no es
sólo el occidente que apoyó al régimen
así sí pero también regímenes árabes
como esos del golfo como emiratos o
arabia saudita que apoyaron así si para
esa para la misma misma razón de la
estabilidad y la seguridad dejamos algún
argumento para vuelta de pagos hacemos
una pequeña pausa y enseguida retomamos
hablando de estos diez años que se
cumplen de las primaveras árabes hoy en
primera plana
[Música]
i
la inmunización en colombia inició este
17 de febrero con las 50.000 dosis de
facer el proceso ha sido fuertemente
criticado por su lentitud y por lo que
algunas autoridades locales han
calificado de exceso de burocracia pese
a que el presidente iván duque calificó
la campaña como un plan masivo durante
la primera jornada llevada a cabo
únicamente en dos departamentos de la
costa solo 18 personas recibieron su
dosis lo que despertó críticas debido a
la complejidad en el transporte del
fármaco que implica una importante tarea
logística desde bogotá lugar donde
aterrizaron y adonde continuarán
llegando las demás vacunas de igual
forma ha habido una reprobación
generalizada al protagonismo que le ha
imprimido el gobierno pues en la segunda
jornada envió a altos funcionarios a las
ciudades capitales donde comenzó el
proceso lo que en algunos lugares hizo
que se demorarán las inoculaciones las
críticas también se han producido porque
al departamento del amazonas donde se
identificaron los primeros contagios con
la variante brasileña sólo se le
adjudicaron 54 dosis se prevé que el
proceso se vea reforzado con la llegada
de 192 mil dosis de la china corona bach
y 50 mil más de facer
[Música]
venezuela arrancó la primera fase del
proceso de vacunación contra el cob y 19
con las primeras dosis de la vacuna ruso
sputnik ve luego que inicio de la semana
pasada a la nación caribeña recibirá de
100 mil dosis tras la firma de un
contrato con rusia personal sanitario
obliga distas trabajadores sociales
cuerpos de seguridad y autoridades que
hacen trabajo de calle entre ellos
gobernadores alcaldes y diputados a la
asamblea nacional serán los primeros en
ser inmunizados la vacunación masiva ha
sido planificada para el mes de abril el
presidente nicolás maduro ha asegurado
que en este primer cuatrimestre del año
llegarán progresivamente más de 10
millones de vacunas compradas a rusia
también ha detallado que la inversión de
su gobierno fue de 200 millones de
dólares la administración de maduro
lleva adelante una negociación con la
oposición para acceder a la plataforma
kóvacs y adquirir otros 15 millones de
vacunas en el mercado internacional el
gobierno venezolano ha insistido que se
le está dificultando obtener recursos
debido a que varios países entre ellos
reino unido portugal españa y eeuu le
tienen congelados al menos 300 millones
de dólares en capitales
uruguay será uno de los últimos países
en recibir vacunas contra el kobe 19 de
sudamérica el ministerio de salud
pública de este país indicó que las
mismas llegarían en el mes de marzo
uruguay llegó a acuerdos con los
laboratorios pzifer sinovac y recibirá
dosis de astrazéneca a través del fondo
kóvacs de la organización panamericana
de la salud 165 mil personas recibirán
la vacunas en la primera etapa estas
eran personal de salud de los
geriátricos y del sistema educativo la
vacunación no será obligatoria y se le
pidiera a las personas que firmen un
consentimiento los expertos indicaron
que esto no facilitará la inmunización
de rebaño pero sí permitirá que se
apliquen los contagios en un país donde
el contagio ya es comunitario la
oposición criticó fuertemente al
gobierno diciendo que se tomaron las
medidas muy lentas y de forma tardía e
incluso criticó que hasta el momento no
se ha comprado la vacuna
incluso cuando este país ofreció que se
fabricarán en uruguay
[Música]
seguimos en primera plana de radio
francia internacional y de france 24
esta semana hablando analizando los 10
años que se cumplen de las primaveras
árabes con crisis de esa guerra y logan
perpiñán
estamos hablando de los diferentes casos
o grupos de países según tuvieran han
tenido un legado u otro a partir de
aquellas revueltas de 2011 tenemos casos
también de incluso de estados fallidos
que antes de la pausa no habían no
sabíamos todavía ha referido a ellos por
ejemplo el caso de yemen de libia a los
que hay que añadir que bashar al-assad o
hoy en día respira más tranquilo en
siria son los tres ejemplos de
llamémoslo invierno ahora veo los
ejemplos de
los que peor han llegado han tenido en
esta revueltas 2011 ahora a mí no me
gusta mucho la palabra invierno
islamista porque da crédito a los
discursos contra revolucionarios
pues eso aparte estos tres pero bueno
interpretándolo como que como causó
conflicto es decir sí sí como como
conflicto sí pero tenemos tres ejemplos
jerry a libia y lleven que hay puntos
comunes que son las injerencias head o
políticas pero al final son tres casos
totalmente diferentes yo hablaré más de
lleven y de libia y dejaré sería para mí
sobre gas sobre el yemen ahora tenemos
un país que está al borde de la hambruna
tenemos de miles y ajustes que contra
una parte del país hay aparcada en la
península arábica que está en otra parte
del país hay un movimiento separatista
al sur y el país está parece totalmente
perdido no sé si todavía se puede hablar
de países en libia para ser un poco
optimista
en libia ahora desde el 5 de febrero
tiene un primer un nuevo primer ministro
que ha sido nombrado por el gobierno
nacional y desarrollo y también por las
fuerzas de estar
pues es una para muchos libros es una
esperanza no sé si va a acabar bien o no
pero es una esperanza está este nuevo
primer ministro viene de misrata del
este del país
y bueno tiene relaciones con todas las
partes del conflicto del conflicto libio
también con los rusos y los turcos que
son actores de terreno ahí y tiene que
preparar nuevas elecciones para
diciembre estos dos países siguen en el
caos para él lleva en va a ser súper
difícil en dentro de unos años de salvar
el país pero ahora hay un poco de
esperanza que nadie últimamente pero
para los ejemplos de siria y libia hay
un poco punto que me parece importante
también es que en esos países hay una
casa una confusión entre el régimen y el
estado el estado es el régimen que
entonces que no hay realmente proximal
es especialmente en línea no hay
instituciones entonces cuando caía
régimen que hay el estado
eso es la principal y eso es una era una
voluntad de por ejemplo el régimen de
gadafi para para mantener la populación
en
controlada y por ejemplo vimos la misma
cosa en irak en 2003 cuando según la
inversión américa y de misma manera que
había una que cayó en el estado y ya no
hay no hay más instituciones países que
han mantenido el status quo como egipto
o el caso de siria esa defensa del
status quo se hizo bajo la fórmula de
esa dicotomía o dictadura de mano dura o
los islamistas los dictadores se
escudaron en ello para recibir apoyo
occidental y del otro lado el islamismo
que entrenó muchas revoluciones cuando
éstas estaban siendo reprimidas este
modelo de dicotomía fue cris pretendido
y buscado tanto por islamistas como por
dictadores sí pero no funcionó
por todas partes por ejemplo en siria
el estado islámico y también al qaida
que surgieron después el levantamiento
popular de 2011 en síria cuando había
una como ir a una subida del
levantamiento popular democrático no
armado es que el conflicto ha sido
transformado en un conflicto militar y
desde la militarización del conflicto
había grupos viniendo del exterior
pagado por arabia saudita qatar y
turquía que cambiaron el carácter de la
rebelión
pero han sido derrotado el estado ha
sido derrotado por los kurdos en cubano
y después ahora se puede decir que los
esfuerzos democráticas de siria
esta alianza árabo kurdo siria que ellos
ponen en práctica un sistema política
muy democrático e igualdad hombre-mujer
y es algo que puede servir como ejemplo
por toda la región en mi opinión es la
única región el norte y el este noreste
de siria donde hay un verdadero
verdadero cambio de la estructura
político-militar de un régimen después
hay una región ocupada por la turquía en
el norte oeste y hay una región retomada
por el régimen decir además que hay una
política en esos países
hay que entender que elisa los partidos
islamistas y sobre todo los los hermanos
musulmanes fueron el partido o la
organización política la más
estructurada después de las banderas
árabes y entonces que teníamos regímenes
regímenes dictatoriales durante durante
aquellos aquellos no
no había no había ninguna vida política
y no habían partidos políticos y
entonces la única estructura política
que es que sobrevivido
fue aquella de los hermanos musulmanes
porque tenían un verdadero mejor
organizado y la mejor organizada y con
una las asociaciones sociales etcétera
y por eso había ese éxito de los
hermanos musulmanes en 2011 pero en sí
tenemos si ponemos en el ejemplo de
túnez a los hermanos musulmanes el
partido de semilla de nada es está en el
gobierno
más o menos hace más de 10 años que
están gobernando pero
ahora hoy son un partido clásico más o
menos clásico que son corruptos como
todos los otros partidos pero también
que participan a la vida política que
tiene elecciones etcétera y entonces se
la dicotomía de islamismo o seguridad
que tenemos que debemos de pasarla para
pero en cualquier caso esa dicotomía yo
me referí a ella porque sí que se ha
sido planteada o ha sido el argumento
que ha estado ahí para plantear para
plantear ciertos en ciertos conflictos
en síria hemos visto esa dicotomía
quizás usada por el propio bashar
al-assad no era el primer interesado en
plantear las sino sí es muy complicado
que hay que definir bien las cosas si
son partidos dicho islamistas políticos
como en la ciudad como en la hermandad
musulmana que se integraron al juego
político y democrático como decía a sara
musulmana en egipto fue resultó al poder
en un círculo democrático de funda
parlantes ys democrática lo que pasa es
que luego es verdad que el amor sí y lo
que vemos son manifestaciones todavía
superiores porque logró penta amor si es
todavía a jugar más a la democracia
claro pero no se puede comprar estos
partidos y milicias de milicias en siria
por ejemplo que son totalmente lejos de
eso
y durante el bueno así que vemos así
fue el único presidente de civil en toda
la historia de egipto eso es un punto
muy importante y también durante después
del de mubarak
hay mucha gente que luego dijo pues mira
si el ejército se mantiene en el poder y
entonces hay el problema con los
hermanos son más musulmanes que se
sientan se sentían amenazados y entonces
intentaron de controlar todas esas
situaciones vamos a avanzar en por más
cosas porque si no nos centramos mucho
en los hermanos musulmanes no sé si la
pero identifica excesivamente bien papel
de la mujer porque muchos dictadores de
entonces nos imaginaron que las mujeres
salían en tal en tal medida de las
calles no harán eso que yo creo que
podemos llamarlo el feminismo de estado
es el feminismo oficial como ben alí
el feminismo de tunecino etcétera pero
bueno en toda crisis social es verdadero
que todas las las minoridades minorías a
lo siento
políticas
la situación va a ser muy complicada
para ellos pero es este mito de la
extracción porque estaba muy mucho más
inseguridad
durante la tiza dura es falso y también
es eso lo que como lo he dicho la había
varios problemas que no lo sabíamos
porque bueno hay muchos muchos derechos
que hay una lucha para muchos derechos
hoy por ejemplo en túnez pero se puede
luchar asistimos en la actualidad un
claro movimiento contrarrevolucionario
con actores de peso como arabia saudita
las monarquías las petromonarquías o el
propio egipto una suma digamos de
fuerzas contrarrevolucionarias que
intentan mantener el status quo en la
región gris claro que sí hay que
comparar por ejemplo en siria la región
a frente y está controlado por la
turquía comparar este con él
esté controlado por los versos
democrática ciudad que es como se
desarrollaba en ellos realmente pusieron
en práctica una igualdad hombre-mujer
contrariamente en donde antón es ocupado
por la turquía y por los mercenarios del
estado islámico y otros grupos radicales
como al-qaida y hay tarjeta sears am
ellos utilizan y la mujer es asesinado
transforma transformado en el esclavo
transferido en libia hay informes sobre
esto no seriamente la práctica político
en el noreste de siria es muy distinta
también otra cosa lo que he visto en
mcgrane donde toda la gente son
musulmanes
era un levantamiento popular de sitios
como mayoría del país contra un sistema
su vida no era un conflicto confesional
no era solamente religiosa era un
conflicto para obtener una democracia
real contra un califato como una
dinastía de al khalifa entonces quedaría
sin tiempo lo siento muchísimo porque ya
es un placer tenerlos a ustedes hoy con
nosotros hablando de estos diez años que
se cumplen de las revueltas de aquel
2011 en el mundo árabe muchísimas
gracias a todos ustedes hasta la próxima
semana en primera plana
[Música]